hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to locked up locked up is
another game made by the same people
that made find yourself which if you
don't remember lixie and hit him with a
flashback as if it was a traumatic
memory and they're remembering it
as if they can't escape the nightmares
of the past
which is probably what this game is
about hit him what is what is this what
is ah helpful
not helpful oh
oh all right i'm gonna run away like a
smart adult get dead
i'm sorry
[Applause]
do i murder the clown
is it murder
yes
it's the only way
murder
[Music]
lixie and prove that i won't look again
by removing my eyes
not very good that's very good almost
too traumatic
anyway this is locked up
oh look at the face actually no it's
just a black screen what are you seeing
in the reflection of your monitor
what is that face it's right behind you
i wish i could turn out the lights i
mean i could turn out the lights i will
turn out the lights you play an
interactive psychological thriller that
takes place in a closed space you have
to interact with the surrounding objects
in order to move along the plot rely on
your intuition and put the story
together the plot is revealed gradually
almost without notes in the game world
it's good to know i'm gonna go turn out
the lights that's really all it did
i mean it's kind of darker but it's
still like day outside so i guess it's a
little better
okay
hello missing child martha foster last
seen thursday april 12 1979 call center
police department at
right it is 707-264-8141 am i supposed
to glean from this
well i guess i'll just leave my car here
mosey on in sure is uh
woodsy
better get a flashlight before i leave
what i didn't have a flashlight oh
i'm a dummy okay that's better yeah
good call
hi
oh that's a problem
that is a problem
if i was in any other situation as soon
as i would see people hanging from trees
i would run
high
uh hi
hello uh uh
hi
oh okay
that also was one of the things that
would make me run away very far very
fast very far and fast
another one
good
and a baby
what did i just miss
hello
hi
uh-huh
oh there it is can anybody else want to
jump out and say hi
no that was not actually an invitation
okay all right
okay
mom and martha
[Laughter]
all right martha
or is it
mom
interesting
this is going to happen to you i can't
tell what's happening
i can't tell what's happening
mom
martha
how you doing martha
how are you doing
hey how you doing hey
i guess i'll look over there now
is this an invitation to sit down and
eat this delicious dinner you guys at
home better be watching with the lights
off
that's all i got to say about that
talking to you
talking to nobody i'm i'm alone in a
room
i'm not talking to anybody i'm literally
alone
recording this for people to watch later
if this game consumed me and murdered me
in my
my sleep no one would ever know before
it was too late
i could already be dead
could be actually if this is watched at
some point in the future it's almost
guaranteed that i'm dead imagine if
aliens find it
like one hard drive left and they pull
it up and it's nothing but markiplier
videos
how advanced do you think our
civilization would be
but they would think our advanced
civilization would be how advan oh
aliens please don't watch this was i
supposed to do something here
well i'm not seeing nothing
mirror oh
i don't like this mirror uh do i do
something
oh
oh good
way wait maybe not good hey wait maybe
not good maybe maybe on good
hey
gosh shut up i hey never say welcome to
my new
yeah i don't like the white robes
uh sugar oh
oh no it's a completely black screen
again
i can't see anything oh 70 oh
oh that's quite a time jump oh god where
am i now well this is much nicer i will
give it that
all locked are ye
are ye
[Music]
are ye lying to me
hello
um
are ye
i can't crouch i can't run
hi
oh please don't i know about opening
doors and it's not a good idea i'm
opening the door
i'm not opening the door is there a
certain combination of drawers that i
gotta
ah okay it's an angry face is that
somewhere here oh it is
oh no
hey
oh i know how to play lighter wait a
minute maybe i don't know how to play
camera lighter i don't have anything
oh hi little strange i didn't notice
these before
what the
okay
oh hi
oh oh didn't like that
oh didn't like that
2 25 am yeah you're darn
tootin it is
okay
deep psychology
search for call members are underway
[Music]
well i'm not exactly sure if i'm just
stumbling across things or i'm so smart
that i'm solving the puzzle
well the music has stopped
oh hey
well
my intuition
it told me that i need to solve things
oh i should ah oh hey i know that house
i think we all know that house
oh hi
you're new
expressway a must
is it though
doesn't seem to be anything interactable
here wait when did you fall hey whoa
mary didn't want to leave our house
yeah i don't blame mary oh gunn
i shouldn't have left him at home
okay
oh
[Music]
search area
the lake
okay
oh
hey
no
no one's in this room
oh
no
hey
cut that out
cut it out right
now oh
hey pills i'll slog those down
bill and matilda the wedding yeah the
wedding
the wedding we all know the wedding
we all know what
that could stop
at any moment that could
[Music]
how about
no oh god oh no
oh no
i mean the name of the game was locked
in wasn't it so i mean i kind of
guessing that i am a little locked in
oh is that the necronomicon
oh am i supposed to put these out they
are a bit of a fire hazard
a poof
oh they're persistent
hey
cut it out
oh
okay
i found the one
only because he told me which one was
the right one
i'm a genius
okay here we are we're back
oh wow
is that a leaf
that's
cool uh
okay
well this is a real nice room
leaf
you're my only friend leaf
i'll keep you forever
oh no
well i've faced situations like this
before and lived
i've even become better for it
try and kill me
oh
god not the squiggly bodies
oh no
oh
no
hi bunny hey bunny hey look look i'm
looking
look
oh
god
i'm looking
what am i looking at
door
man this needs an epilepsy warning hi
oh god it actually opened
what is that about it actually opened i
never expected to actually get out of
that room
ha
oh no
oh here comes oh
bye
hi bye
oh god oh god no
oh
i prefer the noise
i prefer i prefer that i'm going into
the darkness
i better get the night before i leave
you're right
you right
hmm
interesting
ah
oh
[Music]
perfect
what
did you excuse me coatrack i will kill
you i'll straight up murder you
you don't think you can bleed
oh i thought that was a head
oh yeah
that was that applause
aha
interesting
who's there
[Music]
mama's going to buy you a mocking mama's
going to buy you a mockingbird no that
is the that is the lyrics
well
i was crying
not sure if that's a cry
oh
[Music]
okay well i uh
i
thought there was blood on the ground
but it's just the ground looks so
goddamn dirty
was that me
did i do that
please tell me i did that
hi
hello
hi there
oh
that's good
great
what am i doing
oh good it's open hey
candles it's my birthday
oh right fine it's not my birthday
uh
new paintings i'm just such a habitual
decorator stop
stop being you
don't think that you can pull that with
me
i've been through more horror games than
you could possibly imagine
who yes me you
who
stop this nonsense
get me with that
yeah uh-huh
we're gonna bump heads in the hallway oh
okay
uh
well as grand as it is to walk up and
down a hallway which i love to do don't
get me wrong i love me a good pace
um if i could get out of here
that would be greatly appreciated
fantastically appreciated
ball
ball oh i can pick up the ball
yes can i help you
can i help you yes who's there
i'm at the door
oh
you can't keep doing that right when i
come up to the place where i can get out
of here
i am seriously locked in
what do i do with bunny i've never
picked up an object before what do i do
with bunny
what oh it's gone
hello
what
oh open
hey whoo
stop
don't
no
who's there
[Music]
oh
hi
i'm coming for you
nice ass
not
oh hi
jedem das zane
okay well all this is lovely art but
i don't speak german
or latin
or whatever that is
bunny
oh hi
dad we know you're not guilty we hope
you will be released soon with love i
don't think they release people from
prison with love and a smooch
you know what i mean
i'm not 100 sure but i'm fairly certain
i mean there's no better way to signify
someone's been rehabilitated than a nice
kiss on the lips
you can't get out
seems more like you can't get in
i can't move
oh
let them some heavy hand prints oh
those are some fondling hands
okay
i'll take it thank you
what is this
oh no it's the hallway behind me
oh
oh okay
hi
okay
oh more house i've unlocked additional
house
[Music]
a
battery a radio
and a key a key
key from door
which door
from door
hodor
oh
oh something tells me i don't want to be
yes that
this is good
this this is good it does not work are
you sure about that
are you double extra sure are you 100
sure
i haven't gone anywhere i am in the same
i went into a bathroom
i took a dump
and then i went right back into the
nightmare
i have a battery
i cannot do anything with the battery
i am now stuck with this battery
oh
ah
oh no
oh hi
i said it's a door good
that's good picture
hi cockroaches is that an arrow you
giving me a clue are you just weird
crunch
oh good
huh
oh
well
good
oh more house
oh good
oh good oh i
love the art
oh god
suitcase
yep you're right
okay got it
thanks for the clue key to the drawer
i got it
making it easy on me
grandfather clock it is
camera okay
shake it shake it shake it shake it
always love that
love that
well that's dark
whoa it's undeveloped gotta keep shaking
it
well i gotta keep shaking it's not
developed
hi
will you leave me alone
leave me alone
i'll leave me alone if you leave me
alone
leave me alone leave you alone leave me
alone all right whatever
you know what you win
you win
you wanted to win and you got the win
yes
leave me alone
i said leave me alone
okay well everyone's just jiggling
handles over here and that doesn't
really leave me with many options
i guess i am habitually jiggling as well
so i can't exactly complain
oh good
electrical problems
oh good another picture
sub that door
i don't think that's changed
hmm
oh right the door right i need to take a
picture of the door because that's what
the pictures there is for
if only i could run
lexie and make it seem like i'm running
really fast
in the game and in real life if you can
do it
also i forgot wait it's not even any
darker here because it was on auto iso
oh god that's too bright now that's
moody okay anyway picture
ha oh interesting
really
take a picture of you
nice
well
seems kind of spooky
seems like
someone's
right around the corner oh there's a
picture of her
what do i need okay well that's a nice
one that's a nice photograph and that's
just a random piece of wall
you got it bam
nailed that one i did not
how about three two one boom
all right not quite
how about one more how about three two
one bam
i'm not seeing nothing it's it looked
like it was oh this way
no
ah no okay i'll take of the the weird
piece of wall here because it seems to
be shaking here anyway
bastard well that's not nice that's a
little rude
that's a little rude
oh
my god i don't want it
no
uh-huh
do it i'm gonna do it
thanks nike
what am i doing
oh no no no don't do that
oh don't do that
i was just about to try that door
what is that
oh what is that
i don't know what that is
i have no idea what that is i have no
idea hi
hello
oh it does open i was just being an ass
oh my god
hello hi yeah okay
i'll take that picture sure
i'm not gonna turn around
you can't make me look
you cannot make me
oh
a mysterious tilt it is dark
key from door what door
not oh
oh that door
oh
hi
one more picture
yeah
why not this would be a good one
i don't know why you choose to do that i
have a flashlight
oh another one why not
oh good yeah
we wanted to start a new life
yeah well nuts to you you get death
you get death in purgatory
that's what you get
i guess i'll answer the phone
hi oh
keep to the drawer
oddly enough
what the hell did you just do
oh
hi
okay
yes normal that's normal
how's that new life working out for you
my dude
did anyone else's flashlight just go
noir look at the lighting does change
going in here for some reason
not sure why
bible bible
um
[Applause]
alice managed to photograph the evil
that haunted them
good job alice you did it
you really did it
[Music]
got you on camera
yeah
okay
can i help you
that's what i thought
all right
that was completely necessary
it was very necessary
hi
hey what's up sport
okay
[Laughter]
oh that's not so fun
eo
okay
back here again
in this lovely oh you alright pal
okay oh
i know i know that was supposed to be oh
hey
what's up pal
how are you doing
hi
okay
[Music]
man that double bass player is really
wailing on those strings
hi
again
we got him
hi
shut up
talking's kind of my thing
i hate you
i hate you you think about that
[Music]
shut up
okay well that was a pleasant memory
[Music]
what happened
what was what did i just hear
oh no oh no
oh no
okay yeah
okay
[Music]
okay i guess i'm stuck here this is
where i uh i guess i die
right spend the rest of my days
oh my god hi
hi
if it is in the friendly neighbors
[Music]
i'm alive
all right is that a dick that's a
straight-up dick
hi
oh i finally opened the oh good more
house
i was wondering
ah good i want to take a picture of that
curtain who's playing hide-and-go-seek
behind that curtain that's what i want
to know
who who the hell is playing hide and go
seek
ryan on the oh
don't do it
oh you can't come on i know i know i
know someone's had in here
oh
hey
that's not what i thought i saw
hello
oh
okay i didn't even know that was
openable
ah
photograph
great
oh lighter
okay come in handy well i can't use it
ah of course
i am oh my god
i can't even tell i can't even tell
oh my
guess it was just a plant
my imagination
is this what the
the mythical what the no it's not
i'm gonna look
oh
man this game is oh good i thought i was
done
with this errand no apparently not okay
oh no
oh invisible wall thank you
i actually appreciate that
i appreciate that very much
oh hi hey what's up pal
hi
no invisible wall
huh
okay i guess i'm not going that way
oh yes of course we're open now hey
oh
god
i guess i have nothing to say about that
and i will just be on my way
don't you foof me hi hello oh you got a
migraine
you need help i can help
peekaboo
hello you need a pat on the back
rub on the shoulders
i can rub your shoulders
oh hi
it's another perfectly dark
non-reflective surface
i see nothing
oh
hi
well i don't know which way to go first
i guess i'll go see you hey what's up
with your head you got a problem
i can help
i'm gonna kiss it make it feel all
better hello
what am i looking at ah
i am so confused oh i'm back here again
but i can't really understand what it
wants me to
do
you know what i mean
i am oh
i can't believe before i begin my
flashlight
oh hi
hi neighbor you coming to explore a
haunted house in the middle of the woods
too
how good for you
oh there they are
there they are
hey what's up sport
hey how you doing kiddo
okay
i'll just make myself at home then
never mind
i'm gonna go this way i suppose
follow the braziers
the pressures how do you even pronounce
that a burning fire pit it's not like
brazier it's brazier
it's like brendan frazier but brazier
something like that
not important questions to be asking
right now the important question is why
am i being led to a murder cult in the
middle of the woods
and why am i recording it well i guess i
should be recording it just in case
someone finds me so they can prosecute
them for murdering me and these people
i here be dialing a number
i guess it's 1987 maybe i'd oh hi
hey pal you coming to observe too and i
observe only hi okay
that was great
good movie
loved that
i have a lighter now i have lighter now
it doesn't work
great oh
hi
well
this has just been delightful
[Music]
oh my god
that was cheap that was cheap that was
cheap i'll give you a few credits for
getting me
oh
don't do that again
don't you blow me
oh
key to the drawer
was there a drawer over here that was
locked
yes
oh boy another movie
i can't wait
i hope it ends in my death again
all right pop her in turn her on
let's get this party started
here we go again
well all familiar places
but we get the lighter
so that's always good letter from the
employer i have recently completed an
internship at this company and i really
need this job the previous employee did
not finish their work and does not get
in touch collect the remaining personal
belongings of the former residents of
this house leave the packed boxes in the
house and our delivery service will take
care of everything okay
you got it pal this layout is different
oh i'm just starting from a different
place
okay what about the boxes instead of
leave the boxes
i don't know why i'm acting like i'm
actually going to do the job because
there is no way that i'm actually going
to do this job there's every way that
that i'm going to die horribly
he was very impressionable i think it's
just an old house i pat my things
quickly i locked the room because i can
hear someone walking around and
whispering i can't stay here and work
i'm trapped i'm being watched they don't
like me touching their things whoever
finds my letter get out of here you're
not alone here you know they've got some
sense i'm not gonna deny that this house
is kind of creepy and that everyone
should leave as soon as they get here
all i'm saying is who all i'm saying is
that guy has some sense to him
meanwhile me i'm an idiot and just
because i need the job and apparently
need the money does not mean that i
should subject myself to the whims of
ghosts
no
no these are the things that i don't
like
the hell is it
[Music]
key from door
which door
i can take oh hi hey what's up
okay
oh you breaking your own you were
breaking your own bones
oh
hi
i'm here now
take a look at me
oh boy
it's funny because i've recognized this
place because it's been in another
horror game so new game let's just go
into it this one's called
well i'm in the house
oh this is very cute very cute stuff
going on
[Applause]
here and i get that sometimes the assets
that people use in these games spill
over still doesn't stop it from being
scary though which is weird
all right
great
good
no
meet me head on apparently i need this
job and i'm willing to fight ghosts for
it
well
no
no come on
i need to finish back do i
i must
finish
packing
if i don't i would never ever forgive
myself
what do i need to pack i'm packing why
oh
oh my god
really
oh yep you know what this is normal
normal
i've done it i finished packing my job's
complete
my employer will give me a fat big bonus
oh no
[Music]
hi
hello ah it's just clock all along
it was a clock the whole time
here i thought i was
about to be murdered you know i also
don't know why i need to pack this house
up in the middle of the night i feel
like i could have done this in the
daytime
well
something's happening
oh i know what it wants me to do
i'm pat i'm packing i packed
i packed
don't
do that don't
do that
don't do that is that an axe can i have
that
satan
right oh i didn't even see you guys in
there
okay
whoo
i'm trying to do my goddamn job here
and everyone is trying to get my
attention i'm just supposed to pack and
then i go home and then i get paid and
then i go home so just let me do my job
and i will be on my way and you guys
don't have to worry about it i didn't do
anything
fire hazard
oh
[Music]
whoa hi hi
don't foof my lighter
oh hi
okay bye
oh okay bye
okay oh good good good good good good
good good good there we go
i managed to find a way out and left a
note but the house won't let me go and
i'm back in these rooms i'm writing this
letter in the hope that someone will
find it i came on behalf of the social
service to get things but the evil that
lives here does not allow me to do it i
feel like i've been here for a week but
the video camera is still working i've
lost track of time and i'm walking in
circles i was locked up here
all right
don't sniff me
oh why are you sniffing me
i'm
dead
i'm dying
i'm dead
where are we going with all this
ah
it works
again hey
hi
wanna watch a movie bud
hello
interesting
thanks for the hint pal oh
okay
what
the book work the book's gone
need a book i need a book i need a book
i need there's plenty of books there's
so many books grab a damn book all right
whatever i need a book i'll take this
book i took a book
i'm ignoring the whispering in the
darkness and i'm gonna put the book
where the book needs to be and then i'm
going to place the book and i'm going to
turn the book and then the book's going
to open the cabinet and for some reason
this is what i wanted to happen
there's nothing in here
this was a whole waste of my time
don't
stop doing that
stop doing that don't don't stop doing
that
oh
another movie she's cold
i'm trying to watch a movie here
oh
oh um
i think i say uh
oh
[Music]
she is cl oh
oh
hey
okay
hey buddy
wow
it's quite a kaboom
well that was good
oh
ah yeah this is my favorite movie
who's there who's there who's who's
squealing
i love movies i love movies oh good
we're back here
so is there going to be
some kind of purpose to this oh good she
ruled mary
okay
murderer
a murderer
someone's a murderer
oh
hi
key from door
not that one it's never the one that's
closest i always go and go stomping oh
so slowly back to the other so
hi
mary
[Music]
whoa oh hi
okay
i can't exactly help
because i don't know if you're the ghost
or what hi hey how you doing good to see
you again
all right
hello
hi you can't get me there's a desk in
the way so
screw you i guess
what's with the music
[Music]
why is the music all emotional
[Applause]
did we reach some sort of conclusion
did i get an answer
what's with the music
what
what is with the music
[Music]
what
what what is happening
what is happening
what is happening what
but
but what happened
i was but
but i'm why is the music up i was told
that there was nothing in that house
what
why i i'm so confused i am so
i'm so confused
i just wandered around a house
endlessly
oh
no not percentile liberty
help me finish what you started i know
you figured out how to end it it feeds
fears and emotions my loved ones are in
danger
help me finish it
up but
key to the drawer
why
[Music]
you tell me i figured out how to stop it
medical psychiatry frank and detective
paranoid schizophrenia written from the
patient's word
i was not guilty with what happened
mary became dependent on antidepressants
and an evil knew that she had become
vulnerable and seized her she was
compelled to kill our child and
afterwards she did away with herself i
was determined to stay in the home and
get rid of the evil i sealed up the
doors and windows with nails and boards
so it would not find itself new victims
the police stopped me from completing it
and you did not believe me or my
investigation i knew this was an
influential cult that now exists and
their people are in our midst they
continue to kidnap children and other
people they did not give mary any
chances and send me away to prison when
my wife couldn't pay for the apartment
social help offered an old house that
nobody had lived in for a long time
everything that happened to me and which
i saw in that house has appeared to me
in my nightmares
every day is a hell that does not stop
it didn't leave me it's here with me
locked up
[Music]
you have to stay here with us
forever
[Laughter]
[Music]
the game was fine it had a lot of
walking and a lot of going back and
forth so a lot of backtracking but it
did have its scary moments it was like
just enough to keep me engaged and being
like okay what's happening where do i go
i want to see the end of it
but i i i don't know what the hell
happened some cult in the woods that
like
influenced
this dude's wife who killed
their kid and then herself and then he
got another wife that couldn't afford an
apartment and so he was in a psychiatric
hospital and the evil followed it which
i guess technically is good because then
the evil wasn't in the house and so that
other family that asked him to help out
they don't have to suffer the evil
anymore
i guess like just for the scare sake of
the scares not bad i felt like it
dragged on a little bit but not bad for
the scares a lot of back and forth way
too much back and forth but good scares
sometimes so that's what i can say about
it very ambitious but also at the same
time i felt like it could
have done with some trimming and a bit
more story actually coming through
anyway that was uh locked up thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always i've got
scary games out the wazoo down in the
description just click the link and go
to the playlist and you can see all of
them
thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you